Thomas Fitzpatrick, known to his friends as
Tommy Fitz, was a native of Washington Heights,
Manhattan, who, although he had moved to New
Jersey, still hung out with his old friends
from the neighborhood.
A “wild bunch,” Tommy’s crew were adventurous
and enjoyed frequenting area bars.
Late in evening (or rather early in the morning)
of September 30, 1956, as he was leaving a
tavern on St. Nicholas Avenue in Manhattan
to return home, Tommy bet one of his buddies
he could make it back to the bar from New
Jersey in a mere 15 minutes.
This, of course, is impossible by car.
So after leaving the bar on that September
night, Tommy traveled to the Teterboro School
of Aeronautics in New Jersey where he then
stole a single-engine plane.
Hoping to evade authorities until his return
task was completed, he took off without lights
at around 3:00 a.m.
According to reports, his original plan was
to land the plane at the field of George Washington
High School, just a few blocks from the tavern,
but since its lights weren’t on that morning,
a drunken Tommy chose to land the plane in
front of the tavern itself on St. Nicholas
Avenue near its intersection with 191st street-
managing to thread the needle, successfully
avoiding lamp posts and parked cars in his
landing.
Of course, landing a plane in the middle of
a street in Manhattan was bound to get noticed
and the cops were called in.
Eventually charged with grand larceny, Tommy
was never convicted since the plane’s owner,
presumably amused by the whole thing and with
no harm done to his plane, refused to press
charges; however, since the city’s ordinances
prohibited landing planes on its streets,
Tommy was fined $100 (about $800 today) and
had his pilot’s license suspended for six
months.
Just over two years later, again after imbibing
at a Washington Heights bar, Tommy repeated
the feat.
This time, Fitz had been telling the story
of his first flight when another patron questioned
the authenticity of the story- read called
him a liar.
His honor put to the question, at about 1:00
a.m. on October 4, 1958, the inebriated Tommy
again went to the Teterboro School of Aeronautics
in New Jersey and “borrowed” a plane to
fly back to New York City.
This time he landed the plane at the nearby
intersection of Amsterdam and 187th Street.
After landing the plane, he initially fled
the scene.
However, when police were called in and once
again found themselves with a plane sitting
in the middle of a Manhattan street, and recalling
the unique incident two years before just
a few blocks away, they decided to go investigate
and see if Mr. Fitz had something to do with
this one too.
At first, he reportedly denied it, but witnesses
who saw him exit the plane and run off claimed
it was him, ultimately inspiring Fitz to confess.
He later succinctly summed up his decision
making paradigm in choosing to perform the
feat again, stating, “It’s the lousy drink.”
With this second incident, there was no mercy.
The magistrate judge, Ruben Levy, threw the
book at him saying, “Had you been properly
jolted then, it’s possible this would not
have occurred a second time.”
The 28 year old Tommy Fitz was sentenced to
six months in prison for transporting stolen
property.
Beyond his flying escapades and little stint
in prison, Tommy Fitz had a full life, serving
as a Marine in the Korean War and earning
a Purple Heart, enjoying a 51-year marriage
to his apparently understanding wife, Helen,
having three sons, working as a steamfitter
and living to the ripe old age 79, dying in
2009.
While a much easier landing, the aerial adventure
of one Mathias Rust in 1987, and where he
ended up landing, made his trip a little more
historic.
The then 18 year old German had been flying
around Europe in a rented plane when he got
the bright idea to see if he could fly to
Moscow and land in the Kremlin…
Starting from Helsinki-Malmi Airport, and
claiming he was headed to Stockholm before
taking off, Rust made the attempt.
Along the way, he was warned off several times,
had Soviet Air Defense tracking him, and had
soldiers repeatedly requesting permission
to shoot him down, but were denied each time.
On top of uncharacteristic restraint by Command,
a series of gaffes on the military’s part
allowed Rust to make it to the Kremlin without
being destroyed.
However, along the way he decided his original
idea a bad one, as he assumed he’d just
be arrested inside the fortress and that the
government would deny the event, so no one
in the public would know what he did.
Instead, he decided he’d try landing in
Red Square.
However, after a pass over the square, he
found there were too many people walking around
to make that feasible.
He ultimately landed on a bridge by St. Basil’s
Cathedral around 7:00 pm on May 27, 1987.
After the landing, Rust was, of course, arrested,
and ultimately sentenced to four years in
a labor camp in the Soviet Union.
However, two months later as a sign of good
will to the West, Mikhail Gorbachev ordered
Rust be released.
It has been claimed by retired U.S. 3-star
general and former Director of the NSA William
Odom that the military mistakes that ultimately
allowed Rust to penetrate the Soviet Union’s
vaunted defenses and fly over the Kremlin
allowed Gorbachev to remove many of his strongest
military opponents, with the event severely
tarnishing the military’s reputation in
the eyes of the public.
And, indeed, as a result of Rust’s little
adventure, the likes of Sergei Sokolov, the
Minister of Defense Marshal, and Alexander
Koldunov, the Commander-in-Chief of the Soviet
Air Defence Forces, were dismissed from their
positions, among others- according to Odom
helping to expedite the collapse of the Soviet
Union.
Upon returning home to Germany, Rust managed
to make a cool 100,000 DM (adjusted for inflation
and converted to U.S. dollars, about $102,000
today) by granting Stern magazine the exclusive
rights to interview him for his official version
of the story.
Hopefully he saved some of that for a lawyer,
because just two years later Rust was arrested
for stabbing and nearly killing a female co-worker
at West German hospital where he was doing
community service.
The woman in question had reportedly rejected
Rust’s romantic advancements.
Rust ultimately served 15 months in prison
for attempted manslaughter.